le ps va annoncer demain c'est la
majorité de ces investitures pour les
législatives
qu'en est il des soutiens de d'emmanuel
macron je pense notamment à richard
ferrand qui savent caster ils ont été
investis par les militants dans leur
circonscription
est-ce que leur candidature va être
validée par le parti c'est la convention
nationale de demain qui le dira mais il
n'y a pas de raison que ce soit pas le
cas et les choses sont claires
et puis c'est aussi on brasse et déjà
publiques tous les candidats qui ont
l'investiture ont reçu une lettre leur
rappelant ce que ça voulait dire être
investie par le parti socialiste
ça veut dire qu'après la primaire quand
nous aurons notre candidate ou candidat
qui est celui qui gagnera la primaire
ceux qui sont investis par le parti
socialiste devront soutenir ce candidat
pour être clair et pas langue de bois
une fois de plus parce que ceux qui le
soutiennent pas ne seront plus investie
par le parti socialiste